a producer Louis former producer Louis
has made an appearance on my Instagram
account but we'll get to that a little
bit later major major happenings over
the weekend one picture I do want to
show you and by the way i'm on instagram
at david pakman I hope you'll follow me
there right outside the studio there's a
spa it's sort of like two billboard
slots and they change pretty fleet
frequently and at a certain point a few
days ago it was the funniest combination
on the left there was one for weed maps
which is a new app available in
presumably in states that have legalized
recreational marijuana which show you
where the dispensaries are okay and next
to that on the same billboard structure
an ad for a company that tells you there
is evidence for God pat weed maps there
is evidence for God and I've seen that
there is evidence for God people are
advertising on other billboards before
never next to the weed maps and a bunch
of people pointed out that the same
combination was elsewhere in Boston I
wonder if we've Maps deliberately said
we want to buy right next to there's
proof of God people or maybe the
Rastafarians are putting these two
together there's actually a number below
the there is evidence for God billboard
we should maybe even call them and use
that as a segment for the show it's like
eight five five four truth or something
like that I forget what it is I've been
seeing it for years because I'm the
master now I come where around exit
seven or eight there's a billboard for
that there is evidence for God and it's
the exact same phone number so hilarious
combination of billboards near our
studio and it's already changed I don't
know if somebody complained or someone
figured out what was going on but if you
go to the same billboard it's already
been switched up also to the delight of
many many people who follow me on
Instagram at David Pakman producer Lewis
made an appearance on my Instagram
account
Louis along with a mutual friend of ours
and the David Pakman show attorney who
is learning guitar had a jam session
last weekend and the entire I play drums
naturally and I had to play they had
some nice cymbals as you can see the
Zildjian case
but it was this really not I say this
with peace and love I'm sure CB drums is
doing everything they can to make a good
product they're just not that great I
was relegated to playing a CB drum kit
and the entire experience was made a
little more complex by Luis insisting on
on shredding metal riffs at high volume
with high distortion when we were just
trying to have like a casual jam session
and people loving the picture former
producer Louis making an appearance on
my Instagram account what do you make of
all this well you're gonna need a double
bass pedal to play along with metal
riffs it looks like you were able to
take a break for some period of time to
write a picture yes indeed so maybe that
was at a time where everyone was kind of
taking it easy for a little bit yeah
drums let's go with that by the way
there's another music related story
which at some point maybe Pat will allow
me to talk about but that's uh that
that's for another day right we you have
enough scandals going on right now I
don't want to create a new firestorm
yeah let's um let's let's put that off
for another day a follow me on Instagram
Instagram calm slash David Pakman or
search Instagram for David . Pakman